Mazzoni: We're here
to talk to you today
about how to create accessible
interactive web apps
using HTML5.
[female computer voice
speaking indistinctly]
And you can hear
that this talk
is going to be accessible.
We've got some speech
turned on.
If you have any feedback,
here's the link for feedback
and for hashtags if you'd
like to blog about this.
So to start things off,
one way that you can
make your web app accessible
is to keep things
really simple.
Use basic HTML.
Very simple,
easy-to-understand layouts.
And every time that
the user wants to make a change,
you can reload the page
by submitting a form.
Shearer: But, I mean,
that sounds kinda boring.
We want to build web apps
that are interactive
and dynamic
and fun for our users
to use.
We want to build web apps
that feel just like native apps.
And there's no reason
why these interactive
dynamic web apps
can't be accessible to users
with disabilities.
So who are the users
that we're talking about
during this talk?
We're gonna be addressing
three broad groups of users
during this talk.
Blind users,
users with low vision,
and users
who are motor-impaired
and can't use a mouse.
We're gonna be talking about
these three groups of users
even though there are
lots of other users
with different disabilities
that also affect
how they'll use our apps
because at least
for these three groups
we know something
very valuable.
And that's exactly how they're
going to access our page.
Users who are blind would use
a screen-reading software
that describes the page
using synthesized speech
or Braille output.
Users with low vision
will use large fonts
or a screen magnifier,
which increases the size
of the currently focused area
of the page.
And users
who are motor-impaired
will generally use
a special keyboard
or some kind of voice-control
interface.
And these
three groups of users
have one big thing in common,
and that's that none of them
are gonna be using a mouse
to access your page.
So it's really important
when we're building our apps
that we don't make
that assumption,
that we don't assume that
our users are using a mouse.
Because for these three
groups of users,
that's just not the case.
And for these three
groups of users
there really are
no work-arounds.
If our web app doesn't work
with their
assistive technology,
there's really not a whole lot
of recourse for them.
So that's why it's important
for us to get this right
the first time.
And in this talk
we're gonna tell you
how you can do just that.
Mazzoni: So let me
give you an overview
of what we're gonna be talking
about during this session.
First we want to show you
what we think
is a great accessible
experience.
First of all,
how it can go wrong,
and then how we think that
experience can be really good.
Next we're gonna talk about
the actual code,
how you can write your HTML
and your JavaScript
to make things accessible
like in our example.
And finally we're gonna be
talking about
browser extensions
and other tools and resources
that you as developers
can use
to make accessible web apps.
So let's start off
by talking about:
What is a great
accessible experience?
Shearer: So I'm gonna
jump in for a minute
and talk to you exactly
how we're gonna be demoing
our apps and our code
to you today.
Some of you might have noticed,
although this podium's
hiding it,
I'm running this presentation
on a Cr-48 Chrome notebook.
And one of the really great
things about Chrome OS
and something that
we announced at I/O
is that it includes
a built-in screen reader
called ChromeVox
that was developed
by Dominic and my team
at Google.
ChromeVox is implemented
as a Chrome extension,
which means that we wrote it
in just JavaScript,
CSS, and HTML.
And as you can imagine,
it was built for the web.
So we're gonna be using it
to do our demos
for you today.
For those of you
who aren't familiar
with how a screen reader works,
essentially I'm gonna be using
keyboard commands
to move focus
around the page
and explore both static text
and interactive elements
with ChromeVox.
ChromeVox and other
screen readers
work really well
with web forms,
with static text and native
HTML elements.
So I'm gonna
demonstrate ChromeVox
on this embedded web form
in this slide
for you right now.
The first thing I'm gonna do
is unmute ChromeVox
'cause it's been running
this entire time.
[female computerized voice
reading screen]
So what I'm doing
is I'm just using
the ChromeVox modifier keys
shift and search
and using the arrow keys
to move ChromeVox down
through the page.
I'm actually gonna
activate the lens
to show you what
ChromeVox is speaking
in case you can't hear it.
Mazzoni: 'Cause it's very
hard to understand,
especially over speakers here.
female voice: Screen readers
and magnifiers
allow the user to explore
both static--
Here's an example
web form to demonstrate.
Shearer: So I'm gonna
enter the form,
and you can see
how ChromeVox interacts
with interactive elements.
female voice: Enter your name.
Editable text.
Red. Choose your favorite color.
Combo box with ten.
Shearer: So I'm gonna choose
my favorite color
using the arrow keys.
female voice: Orange,
two of ten.
Yellow, three of ten.
Green, four of ten.
Submit button.
Having trouble?
Click here for help, link.
Shearer: So that was great.
ChromeVox jumped through--
It read to me
the static text,
and it jumped into each
of the focusable controls,
told me what the control was,
and told me how I could
interact with it.
Mazzoni: I'm gonna jump in
and say one more thing here,
which is that, for that people
who have low-vision,
they might be using a tool
called a magnifier,
which works in a very
similar way.
Instead of listening
to the speech
and the sound effects
that you heard,
they're simply
going to be looking
at a magnified version
of one part of the page.
Kinda like the lens
you see at the top.
So the experience
is very similar.
The idea is you're focusing
on one part of the page
at a time
and having it
described to you
or magnified or enhanced
in some way.
Shearer: And the great
news here is that
if the web app you're building
looks just like this form
then congratulations,
your website will be accessible
and a user can use
a screen reader
to go through all of your
editable text and buttons.
But if your web app is maybe
a little bit more exciting,
if it has a little bit
more going on
and it's a little bit
more complex,
then we do have to do
some extra work
in order to give our users
a good experience.
And that's what we're gonna
talk to you about.
Mazzoni: So let's start by
talking about a bad experience.
So in contrast to that form,
here's--this is certainly
not a complex app,
but this is an app that uses
a few more interactive
capabilities
that you find in just about
every interactive
Web 2.0 app today.
So this is a little app
we built called Snack Attack,
and the idea is simply
you're gonna scroll through
these list of choices
and vote on the ones
that are your favorite
for hacking all night long.
So I'm gonna first
demonstrate this
from the perspective that
most web developers
would be thinking about,
which is someone
who's using a mouse
and who is fully-sighted,
able to see this page.
So I'm going to look
at this page
and look through these choices.
And some coffee sounds
really good right now
so I'm going to click
on coffee.
And now a dialog box
appeared.
Now as web developers,
we all know this isn't
a native dialog box.
But it feels like
a dialog box
because it appeared
over top of the page.
Everything else
was sort of dimmed.
And there's some controls for
me to interact with.
So this is good. It wants me--
I see some stars.
And it looks like
this is an opportunity
for me to rate this.
I'll give this four stars.
And there's a "vote"
and a "cancel" button.
I click "vote."
Now it says "saving,"
and the dialog box disappears.
So so far this sounds like
a great experience.
Now let's suppose that
the only limitation I have
is that I'm unable
to use a mouse.
Millions of people out there
do all of their computer use
using only a keyboard.
They might even have some type
of special assistive device
that simulates a keyboard.
So I'm just gonna press tab.
And as I press tab,
you'll notice
that various
focusable controls
on the page
are being highlighted.
So let's try the exact
same experience.
I go here to coffee,
and I hit enter,
and the dialog box
appears.
So far, so good.
Now let's say
I wanna actually interact
with the dialog.
I'm gonna press tab again.
Hmm, nothing happened.
I'm gonna hit it again.
Oh, this is terrible.
The focus is behind
the dialog,
so this is a poor experience
for me as a keyboard user.
But maybe if I'm clever
and I keep pressing tab
or shift-tab in this case
I eventually find myself
inside the dialog.
You'll notice now "vote"
is focused.
So I'm inside the dialog,
but it's not a great
experience for me.
But how 'bout
the star rating gadget?
Can I interact with that?
Well, no, it just
skips right past it.
So this page is basically
inaccessible to me
as someone where
my only limitation
is that I can't use
a mouse.
Unfortunately it can be
even worse than that.
So let's turn ChromeVox
back on again.
And now I'm gonna interact
with the same page
as a blind user.
female voice: Sign up, link.
About, link.
Contact us, link.
Mazzoni:
We can turn on the lens
to see exactly
what it's saying.
female voice:
Pizza delivery, link.
Caffeinated soda, link.
Mazzoni: So let's suppose
that I want to click
on one of these.
female voice:
Click.
Mazzoni: So I just clicked
on one of those links,
and the dialog box appeared.
But unfortunately nothing
else was spoken,
nothing else was said.
So I don't have any idea,
as a blind user,
what just happened.
A dialog box
might have appeared.
Something could have
happened.
It could have done something,
but I don't know what happened.
If I were to continue
to explore the page,
I might discover that there's
some things on the page.
female voice: Cancel, button.
Mazzoni: I might discover
that this cancel button
and this vote button
weren't there before.
And I notice
there's something here
that says "no rating."
So I might be able to infer
that there's some sort
of ratings gadget.
But if I were to press
a bunch of keys,
there would be no way for me
to actually interact with it,
and I don't even know what
type of gadget that is.
And one last thing--Oops.
Ha ha. Hit the wrong key.
I'm sorry about that.
[female voice
speaking rapidly]
One last thing is if I hit
the "vote" button,
it doesn't say that it's
been saving anything.
So this is the last problem
with this experience.
So as you can see we have
a lot of work to do
in order to make this
experience accessible.
Let's mute everything here.
So what went wrong?
We had poor focus management.
We had an unusable
custom control
that didn't have
keyboard commands
for me to interact with.
And there was no
explanation to the user
when things changed
on the page,
like a dialog box appearing
or a saving message appearing.
Shearer: So what should
have happened?
First of all,
we should have been managing
our focus better.
We want the user to fill out
the dialog.
So when the user
clicks the button,
we should have thrown focus
inside of that dialog
so that the user could then
interact with it.
We should also have made sure
that focus stayed
inside the dialog
so the user
wouldn't accidentally
fall out of the dialog
as they're exploring.
The second thing we need to do
is make sure that
we could use the keyboard
to interact with
our custom controls.
You saw that that
star rating widget
didn't accept any keyboard
input at all.
And so that's really bad
for these users
that aren't using a mouse.
They're using the keyboard.
Controls need to be labeled
for screen readers.
You saw that ChromeVox
didn't even recognize
that that gadget
was interactive at all.
So someone who's
using ChromeVox
doesn't un--wouldn't be able
to figure out
how to vote
for a particular snack.
And the way that we can actually
label our custom controls
is by using special markup,
and we'll go more into
that later.
And finally,
the user needs to be informed
when things change
on the page.
There were two instances--
the first one,
the dialog opened,
and the second when
the word "saving" appeared--
that nothing was spoken
by ChromeVox at all.
Those changes
were happening outside
of the currently
focused area.
And we can also add
special markup
to let the user know
when those kinds
of changes are happening.
Mazzoni: So let's take
another look this time
with all those problems fixed
and see what
the experience can look like
when we've made it accessible
to users with this type
of assistive technology.
I'm gonna skip past the case
of the keyboard-only user
because you can
sort of imagine the experience
once you've seen the experience
with the screen reader.
So let's turn--
female voice:
HTML5. Sign up, link.
Mazzoni: So let's turn
ChromeVox back on.
And I'm going to go through
the exact same experience
and let's see
what happens here.
female voice: About.
Contact us.
Pizza--
Caffeinated soda, button.
Mazzoni: Okay, so now
I've got something--
I've chosen the item I want
to click on.
Let's see what happens
when I click on this.
Actually I'll turn on
the lens again
so you can see it
hopefully.
Let's just listen this time
what happens
when I click on something
and enter dialog.
female voice:
Please rate this snack.
The rating from zero,
max five, slider.
Mazzoni: So what
it said there was,
first of all it said
"entering dialog."
And then it told us
that we're on a slider.
Well, this is great.
So a slider is a control
that I'm already familiar with
working with.
And so if I were on
any slider normally,
I might use the arrow keys
to interact with it.
And in fact
this is gonna work great.
female voice: One star,
eww gross.
Two stars--
Mazzoni: So just by
pressing the arrows,
it's changing
the value of the slider
and reading
the new value to me,
and in addition
to the value
also some sort of
description for it.
So this is great.
Now let's hit
the vote button
and see what happens here.
female voice: Click.
Saving.
Mazzoni: So notice that
it said "saving,"
which is great.
So basically everything
that happened on this page
was--also had a great
accessible experience
to go along with it.
And again this is nothing
super fancy or complicated.
We want to show
that this is something
that's not very mysterious
and it's not that hard
to imagine.
With some simple changes,
you can make sure
that all users can get
the same great
interactive experience
with your site.
female voice:
[indistinct] HTML5.
Mazzoni: So let's go on
to the second part here,
which is how to code
accessible HTML5.
So as an overview,
there are four basic areas
we wanna talk about
in order to create
accessible HTML5.
First of all,
we just want you to use
clean HTML and standard tags
whenever possible.
This is just a good, solid
foundation to build on.
Then the next step
is to manage focus.
And then add keyboard handlers
for custom controls
that need it.
And then finally once you have
that experience as a baseline,
you can add ARIA,
which is a new HTML5
markup for screen readers.
We've found it works really
well if you do it in that order.
Shearer: So the first step
that you wanna think about
when you're developing an app
is clean HTML
and standard tags.
And this might seem
like really basic advice,
but it's really important
for these users
who are basically
navigating the page
by moving focus around.
Using CSS for layout,
making sure that your content
and layout are separated,
and making sure
that your DOM order is logical
means that you're writing
cleaner HTML.
And cleaner HTML is actually
more accessible HTML.
And so that's something that's
important to remember.
The second thing that
we wanna think about
is don't reinvent the wheel.
Don't use a generic
div or span tag
when there's
a native HTML tag
that's more appropriate.
There's a lot of benefits
to using native HTML tags
that you don't get with
generic divs or spans.
Mazzoni: And I think a lot
of web developers
were in a habit--
a few years ago,
there were a lot of tags
that weren't possible
to style fully with CSS.
But today you can style
everything with CSS,
so there's no reason not to use
the appropriate semantic tag.
Shearer: And native HTML tags
have focus
and keyboard handling
built in,
so it means that
you don't have to go back
and add those later.
And screen readers are really
good at identifying
native tags to users.
And users are very good
at interacting with those tags.
So instead of doing extra work
on a generic div or span,
using a native tag
at the beginning
will save you
down the road.
And the final thing
you wanna think about
is labeling your images
and form controls.
For an image, this means
using an alt tag
with a text description
of the image.
And for a form control,
using the label tag.
This is really basic advice,
as I said before.
But at the beginning of
your app development process
is the time to do this.
Going back later after you
have a fully mature app
is really a huge pain.
So it's better to do this
as step one.
Once you've got
your clean HTML,
you want to start thinking
about focus.
Focus management is really
important for these users.
And as I said before,
it's better to use
a native HTML tag,
but often we do want to do
more complex things
that you can get with
a bunch of divs and spans
and onclick handlers,
and that's fine.
But we really
need to make sure
that those custom interactive
controls that we're creating
are focusable.
Only link tags
and native HTML tags
receive focus by default.
So any time we're
creating a control
with a pile
of divs and spans,
we need to make sure
that we're making it focusable.
And the way that we do that
is with tabindex.
I'm sure many of you already
know how tabindex works.
We have a refresher for you
up on the slide.
But the really important
thing to remember
is just, if you're
using a custom control,
make sure it's focusable.
Once you've done that,
you want to start thinking
about how you can
manage your focus.
And the way
that you do that
is with the JavaScript
focus method.
And you can also
listen for focus events
to make sure that you're
managing focus
after the user has started
moving focus around the page.
We did that in the demo
by placing focus
inside the dialog
after it opened
and trapping focus
inside the dialog
after the user
was interacting with it.
Mazzoni: So once
a control has focus,
you want to make sure
that someone can interact
with that control
using the keyboard
just as easily as someone
can interact with it
using the mouse.
If you're not sure
what keys to use,
sometimes the easiest
thing to do
is just to try out
the native control
that's most similar
to the control
that you're simulating
and try a bunch of keys
on your keyboard--
the arrow keys,
page up, page down,
escape, enter, space--
and see what they do.
But there's plenty
of resources online
on how to do this.
The important thing is that,
when you're testing out
your app,
you should try
unplugging your mouse
and see what happens
as you interact with things
and make sure that
a keyboard user
has the same experience.
And luckily this is
very easy to do.
We've given an example here
where something
that's clickable
can also be activated
using the space bar
or the enter key.
Shearer: The important thing
to remember there
is that, if you're listening
for a click event,
it's a good idea
to try and think about
listening for an enter event
or a space event also.
Once you've gotten
your clean HTML,
your focus,
and your keyboard handling,
it's time to start thinking
about ARIA.
And ARIA is markup
that you add to your page
to identify those fancy
custom controls you created
with divs and spans
to a screen reader.
As I said before,
screen readers are really
great with native tags,
like button,
but when you have a bunch
of generic tags,
it's impossible
for a screen reader
to figure out what you mean
by that pile of divs.
You could be trying
to build a button,
or you could be trying
to build something
as complicated as
a full menu interface.
So ARIA markup is the tags
that you add to your HTML
in order to indicate
to the screen reader
how they should identify
that control to the user.
And there's two types
of ARIA tags.
The first one is called
the ARIA role attribute,
and you put that
in your HTML
to indicate what the
generic tag that you're using
is trying to be.
So in this example,
we've got a div
that's acting as a button.
So we have the ARIA
role equals button.
When a screen reader
gets to that div,
it will say that this
is a send button.
Roles are static, and you'd
set these in your HTML
like you see here.
The other kind of
ARIA property
is called an ARIA state
or property.
ARIA states and properties
add dynamic information
about the current state
of an element.
So you see in this example
we have a div
that we're using
as a check box.
So we have the ARIA role equals
check box on that div,
but we also have
an ARIA state
called "aria-checked."
And this tells
the screen reader
that not only is this div
acting as a check box,
but this div
is currently checked.
And so when
the screen reader gets there,
it will say that this
is a checked check box.
As you can imagine, ARIA states
and properties are dynamic,
and so you'd want to update
these in your JavaScript
as the control
is being updated.
In this slide,
I want to talk about
a more specific
kind of ARIA tag,
and that's
the ARIA Live Region tag.
We mentioned earlier
that it's important
to identify to users
when things are changing
on the page
maybe outside of
the currently focused area.
When you have changes
on a page
that are happening
without a page refresh,
you can identify them
to a screen reader
using Live Regions.
In this example you see
that we have a span.
And this is actually
taken from the example
that Dominic showed you
where you clicked
the "vote" button
and it wrote the text
"saving."
And we have an aria-live tag
on this span.
And that tells
the screen reader that,
when the screen reader
gets to the span,
"Hey, this span is gonna
receive updates.
"So you should keep an eye
on this span
and speak any updates
that happen to it."
And you saw
that ChromeVox did that.
When he clicked "vote,"
ChromeVox actually said,
"saving."
And so that tells the user
extra information
that they wouldn't have known
if the ARIA Live tag
wasn't there.
The value of
the ARIA Live tag
is any number of
different politeness levels.
And I'm not gonna go into
too much detail
on politeness levels,
but the important thing
to remember
is it actually is a way
of controlling
how quickly the screen reader
interrupts someone.
So we've set it here
to be polite,
which means that ChromeVox
is gonna wait
until it's finished speaking
what it's currently speaking
before it interrupts the user
and says "saving."
There are also
certain ARIA roles
that are considered live
by default.
Like in this example
the ARIA role equals alert.
So it's just really important
to kind of manage
the different regions
on your page
that are changing
without a page refresh,
and ARIA Live
will help you do that.
Mazzoni: Okay, so we've
given you a lot of ideas
and talked about a lot
of technical details,
but there's nothing better
than an actual example
to see how this works
and how--in many cases,
how easy it is
to make things
fully accessible.
So we've got a few examples
we've prepared here,
and we're gonna start with
a really simple one here.
We've got a custom button.
There are a lot of reasons
why you might have
something on the page that
doesn't look like a button
but it essentially
acts like a button.
And just as
a quick reminder,
what's going to happen
when we haven't had
any accessible markup here,
I'm gonna turn
ChromeVox back on here.
female voice: Send refresh.
Example one.
Click on this button.
Send.
Mazzoni: So you notice when
I got to the send button
with ChromeVox
it just said "send."
It didn't say it was
a button.
And in fact if I tried
to click on it,
nothing would happen
because it doesn't appear
to be any type
of focusable control.
So let's make
some changes here.
The first change
we wanna make
is we want to add
tabindex equals zero.
And just by making
that change,
when I hit tab, now I can
reach the send button.
Now you notice
that screen readers
will be able to reach things
even if they aren't focusable.
They just won't be able
to interact with them.
Now someone can reach
and interact with it.
But we're not quite
done here,
because we haven't
described this as a button.
So I'm gonna add
the ARIA tag
role equals button.
Now let's turn
ChromeVox back on.
female voice: Send, button.
Mazzoni: So now it describes
it as a send button.
And in fact it's something
that I can click on
and interact with
using ChromeVox keys.
So really simple example.
What I haven't done here
is a keyboard handler.
So that would be
the last step you'd need to do,
is to handle
the keyboard handler
for someone who's not
using a screen reader
but can't use a mouse.
Shearer: So I'm gonna take
the second example.
This is another button.
It's similar to the one
Dominic just showed you.
We've made it using a div
and some CSS styling.
And probably the first thing
that we're gonna want to do
is also add tabindex
and the ARIA role.
So I'm gonna do that now.
Tabindex is, as I said before,
really important.
Anytime you're using a div
or a span
to make a custom control,
you want to make sure
you're setting tabindex.
And now I'm adding
role equals button.
And let's see
what ChromeVox does.
This button is a little bit
more complicated,
so I'm gonna have to do
some extra work here.
female voice: Example two,
toggle button.
Toggle, button.
Shearer: So that's great.
It said "toggle, button."
I'm gonna click on it.
female voice: Clicked.
Shearer: So it said "clicked."
That's awesome.
But you'll notice
that the button
actually turned
a different color,
and that's because,
as you might have guessed,
this slide is called
"Toggle button"
and this is
a toggle button.
So when I move away from it,
it's gonna stay on.
female voice: Toggle, button.
Shearer: And when I moved
ChromeVox back to it,
you'll notice that it just said
"toggle, button."
There was no indication to me
that this button
is currently pressed
and that it's
gonna stay pressed.
So this is an example
of a place
where you'd want to add
an ARIA state,
a dynamic property
that changes
based on whether the button
is on or off.
And when I add that,
hopefully ChromeVox
will start telling me
whether or not this button
is on or off.
And so,
as I said before,
we're gonna want
to set these states
inside our JavaScript.
I have this function here
called toggle,
and inside this first half
of the if statement
I'm gonna set the attribute
aria-pressed,
and I'm gonna
set it to false
in this half.
And in the other half,
I'm gonna set the attribute
to be true.
True.
And I'm also gonna
initialize it inside the HTML
so that we can say that
the default state of this button
is off.
False.
Okay, so let's try it out.
Hopefully things have
improved a little bit.
Turning ChromeVox on.
Oops.
That is the next example.
Spoiler alert, okay.
female voice: Example two,
toggle button.
Toggle.
Button not pressed.
Shearer: Okay, so you heard
that ChromeVox
actually gave me a little bit
more information.
It said, "button not pressed."
So when I click the button,
let's see what happens.
female voice: Pressed.
Shearer: So it says--
Instead of "clicked,"
it says "pressed."
So I'm pressing the button.
I'm gonna move away from it
to the next link.
female voice: Refresh button.
Shearer: And now
I'm gonna move back,
and let's see
what happens.
female voice: Toggle,
button pressed.
Shearer: So that's great.
It told me that the button
was actually pressed.
So this means that
now we have a button
that has a state that
the screen reader will tell me
what the current state
of this button is.
So it's building on
a little bit
Dominic's first example.
Mazzoni: Let's do
a couple more examples here.
Actually,
the next one's yours.
Shearer: Oh, right.
Oops.
This next example
is also mine.
This is another button,
but you'll notice
that we've used
a native button tag,
so I don't have to go through
and add tabindex
and role again
for the third time.
That would be
a little bit overkill.
So we have this button.
And let's just see what happens
when I run ChromeVox on it.
female voice: Example three,
status indicator.
Click to begin
calculation.
Calculate, button.
Shearer: All right,
I'm gonna press the button.
female voice: Clicked.
Shearer: So--and silence
from ChromeVox.
So clearly this button
is setting off
some kind of complicated
calculation.
The text box below the button
says that it's calculating,
and then about a second later
it says that it's finished.
But ChromeVox was totally
silent that entire time.
So I as a user
have no idea
that anything
happened at all.
And some of you
might be guessing
that the way to fix this
is by using ARIA Live Regions,
because this div with with
the ID of status down there
is what's receiving
these text updates.
So I'm gonna add
the aria-live attribute.
I'm gonna set it
to be polite,
because we don't want
to be rude.
And let's see
how ChromeVox does.
female voice:
Click to begin--
Calculate, button.
Shearer: Okay,
I'll click "calculate."
female voice: Clicked.
Calculating.
Finished.
Shearer: Great,
so this is awesome.
ChromeVox said that
it was calculating,
and then it said
it was finished.
So I as the user
now have a better idea
of what's actually going on
on this page.
Mazzoni: So you can see that
with just a few simple changes
based on HTML standards
you can make some big changes
to the user experience
that people get when they're
using assistive technology.
Let's take a couple
of other examples.
This one's a little bit
more complicated,
but let's talk about how
we made the star rating gadget
from the dialog earlier
accessible.
You might recall
that we decided
to make it into a slider
because that was sort of
the closest control
that's already part of ARIA
that users are already
familiar with
that sort of simulates
what the experience
of working with
this custom widget is like.
So I'm not even gonna show you
the inaccessible experience
because without making
any changes,
as you can imagine,
this would be
completely inaccessible
to a screen reader
or to a keyboard user.
So let's start making
some changes here.
You know the first one
is tabindex equals zero.
The second one here is
role equals slider.
And just that change alone
is gonna be enough
for ChromeVox to announce
that it's a slider,
but that's not enough
in order to describe
the current state
of the control.
So the slider role in ARIA
comes with a bunch
of extra attributes,
which I'm gonna add now.
ARIA value min equals zero.
ARIA value max equals five.
ARIA value now equals three.
And just to be
a little bit more clear,
aria-valuetext equals
three stars.
So instead of just saying
the value is three
out of five,
we can give it
a special label
and say three stars.
So we haven't made this
interactive yet,
but let's go ahead and see
exactly what happens.
female voice: Rate from
one to five stars.
Three stars.
Min zero, max five.
Slider.
Mazzoni: That came
a little fast,
and if you didn't
quite hear it,
it said that
it was a slider.
It said there was
a min zero, max five,
and that the current value
is three.
Three stars.
So this is great.
Now the only other thing
we need to do
is make this
actually interactive
with the keyboard.
I went ahead and built
the key handler earlier.
So I can just write
return star key.
Shearer: You're outside
of the tag.
Mazzoni: Oh, thanks.
I'll fix that in a second.
And if I did this right...
Cool, now it's interactive.
female voice: Four stars.
Min zero, max five.
Three stars.
Mazzoni: So notice
that simply by adding
the keyboard handler support--
because this is properly
marked up with ARIA
and because
my keyboard handler modifies
the ARIA attributes
dynamically,
the screen reader automatically
does the right thing.
It speaks the new value
when the control changes.
So that's the star rating
gadget example.
And let's do one more,
which is the pop-up dialog.
So you saw earlier
that we had a dialog.
And the accessibility problem
with the dialog--
I don't even need a screen
reader to demonstrate this.
You start with a button,
and you click on the button
and it opens a dialog,
but focus isn't
inside the dialog.
So you saw how this
is a bad experience
for just about all the users
that we're considering here.
So the first change
I'd like to make
is just to focus
the "OK" button
when we enter the dialog.
A simple change like this
is gonna create
a much better experience
for a keyboard-only user.
Now the initial focus
is inside the dialog.
Now let's focus on
the screen reader user.
And I'm gonna say
role equals dialog
on the outer dialog
element there.
And I'm gonna do
one more thing here,
which is add aria-label.
This is optional,
but it'll create
an even better experience.
We can call this
a confirmation dialog.
So now let's turn on ChromeVox
and see what happens.
female voice: Buy more
printer ink, button.
Mazzoni: Okay, so "buy more
printer ink, button."
Now I'm gonna click this
and see what happens.
female voice: Entering
dialog confirmation.
OK, button.
Mazzoni: Great, so this said,
"entering dialog confirmation."
So now I know that
I'm inside the dialog
and that I'm
in an "OK" button.
So this is already a much
better experience before.
There's only one more problem,
which is that it's possible
for me to escape
outside the dialog.
female voice:
Cancel, button.
Refresh, button.
Exiting dialog.
Mazzoni: So this isn't
a terrible experience.
At least it told me that
I exited the dialog.
But that isn't exactly
the experience
that I would like to deliver
for users as a developer.
I'd like to actually keep focus
trapped inside the dialog
because I want the user
to either press the "OK" button
or the "Cancel" button.
And so we can do that with just
a little bit of JavaScript,
but it's a little more
JavaScript
than I wanna type live,
and so I typed it
ahead of time,
and I'm gonna
paste it in here.
But essentially
all it's doing
is adding some
event listeners.
And if I pasted that
in the right place...
great.
So what's happening now
is that even as
I keep pressing tab,
it's keeping me
inside the dialog.
And if I press shift-tab,
it's going to keep me there.
You can see it
flicker a little bit,
'cause what's happening
is the browser's
allowing the focus to move
outside the dialog.
I'm listening
on the focus event
and just moving it
right back inside.
And this is something that
works for screen readers.
It works for people
who are using the keyboard,
and this creates
a much better experience.
One last--Whoo.
It really wants to keep things
trapped inside the dialog.
Okay, one less
compatibility note.
We've designed
all of these examples
to work with not just
ChromeVox and Chrome OS,
but all the examples
we showed you
is standard HTML5.
It's part of the ARIA standard,
and it's part of
just standard HTML5
and JavaScript that you've
been using for a while.
And all these examples work
across a variety of browsers
and popular screen readers
and magnifiers.
We've listed some of them
here on the page.
There are some platform
differences,
but the good news is that
a couple of years ago
this would have been
difficult to deliver
to very many users.
And today the latest
versions of browsers
and the latest versions
of mini screen readers
already support
everything you saw here,
and so you can deliver
this great, accessible,
interactive experience
from a single code base.
Shearer: So now that you've seen
all of our different examples
and seen how we're using
the advice that
we're giving today,
I just wanted to do
a quick recap
of what we've said.
Number one, use clean
HTML and standard tags.
Remember that clean HTML
is generally
more accessible HTML.
And this is important
to do first as opposed to later.
Number two, manage focus.
Make sure that your custom
interactive elements,
your fancy divs and spans
with onclick handlers
have tabindex on them
and that they can receive
keyboard focus.
And this is--you can also then
proactively manage your focus
by using the JavaScript
focus method
and by listening
to how the user
is trying to move focus
around the page.
The third thing
is making sure
that your controls
are usable with the keyboard.
Add key handlers.
Make sure that a user
doesn't have to have a mouse
in order to use your
fancy slider widgets.
And finally add ARIA
for screen readers.
And the good thing here
is that if you've already
done the first three steps,
it should be easy
to find the correct ARIA role
for the control
that you're trying to build.
And if you can't find one
that matches exactly,
find one that approximates
the interaction style
that you want.
And make sure that
you're updating your dynamic
states and properties.
And make sure that you're
identifying your live regions
to the user.
Mazzoni: I have one more note
that I'd like to make here,
which is that
this is something
that didn't come up
with ChromeVox
but is an issue
with a few screen readers,
which is that some
screen readers are modal.
And by modal all I mean
is that the screen readers
have a mode where
all of the keys the user press
go directly
to the screen reader
and not to the web page
or any other app.
This can be convenient
because it means
you don't have to hold down
modifier keys
while you're interacting
with the screen reader.
But the problem is,
is that you can't,
as a web developer,
assume that someone
who's using a screen reader
is able to always press keys
that your application
can listen to.
But luckily, there's
a very easy solution,
which is that whenever the user
has focused a control,
then any keys they press
are going to be sent
to that focused control.
So if you just
keep that in mind
and just remember that
global key handlers
may not always work,
but that keys on specific
focus controls will work,
then you can build something
that'll be compatible
with the majority
of screen readers out there.
There's one alternative
for more advanced developers,
which is
the ARIA role application.
You can set a certain
port of the page
or the entire page
to be a web application
which listens
to all keyboard events
and sends nothing
to the screen reader.
There's some caveats
in working with this,
but this can be
a great way
that you can build
a very custom experience
if you want to do that.
Shearer: So in the last
part of our talk,
we want to talk about
some of the opportunities
that are available out there
if you're a developer
interested in accessibility,
which I'm sure
all of you are.
But first,
before I start talking
about the cool things
that you can do,
I want to talk about
some of the limitations
that are out there,
unfortunately.
Specifically with some of
the advice that we gave you
like ARIA, there are wide
implementation differences
at this time between browsers,
platforms, and screen readers.
And what is implemented
can be buggy and quirky.
If your user base is customers
who are using older browsers
and older screen readers,
at this time the best way
to reach those customers
is still writing
a static HTML page.
So if that's
your customer base,
a static HTML page
is the best way to reach them.
But you guys are here
at Google I/O.
You want to learn
about cool, emerging tech,
and the great thing
about ARIA
is that it's kind of
in the same place
as HTML5 generally.
The spec is really ambitious.
And it's implemented
in some places better
than it's implemented
in other places.
But at the same time,
there's a lot of stuff
that works really well
everywhere.
And we showed you
a few of those today.
So there's no reason to wait
until things settle down
to start hacking
and building cool tools
with the stuff
that is available.
Mazzoni: So we want
to talk a little bit
about the power
of browser extensions.
You know that we've been demoing
these things using ChromeVox,
which is built
as a browser extension.
And browser extensions
in the last couple of years
have really become
a lot more powerful
because you don't have
to restart your browser anymore
when you want
to install an extension.
You don't have
to worry as much
about what types
of privileges
that extension might have.
You know exactly
what sites and what things
it has access to.
And because of all this,
we think that
browser extensions
are a perfect platform
not only for accessibility
solutions for end users,
like we've been demonstrating
with ChromeVox,
but also for developers
who want to test things out
for accessibility
and who want
additional tools
to help make their websites
more accessible.
So we'd like to talk about
three of Google's extensions
that we've developed
that you might find useful
or inspirational
for other ideas or extensions
that you might
be interested in building.
Shearer: The first one
we want to talk about
of course is ChromeVox.
It's built into Chrome OS.
But because
it's a Chrome extension,
you can install it on Chrome
on any platform
and use it as a screen reader
inside the browser.
It's implemented
as JavaScript,
which means that it's
basically built for the web.
It uses the new Chrome
experimental TTS API
to do text-to-speech.
And it also uses
some special Chrome OS APIs
to listen for user interface
events in the Chrome of Chrome.
Which means that
when you have your Chrome OS,
your Chromebook that some
of you are gonna be getting,
it actually will speak
the sign in dialog.
It will speak the menus
that you open
in order to change
the settings.
And so that's
really great too.
It's speaking the Chrome
of Chrome for you.
And for ChromeVox
the goal is really
to have the best support
for HTML5 and ARIA,
because this is
a screen reader for the web.
And if you want
to go beyond that,
we also support
custom scripts
that you as a developer
can add to your site
if you want to add
the extra level
of interactive accessibility
beyond what ARIA and HTML5
allow you to offer.
The second extension
that we've done
is called ChromeVis.
And this is an extension
that we made
for low-vision users.
It's basically a type
of screen magnifier.
We released it last summer,
and the goal with ChromeVis
was to kind of take advantage
of the power of extensions
to allow users to customize
their entire web experience.
There's a lot of different
types of low-vision users.
They all have different needs.
And ChromeVis allows them
to modify almost everything
about this magnified lens.
Basically users will select
text on the page,
and ChromeVis will display
that selected text
in this special lens.
And users can change
the color.
They can change
the size of the text.
They can even change
the position of the lens.
And so we really
see extensions
as a really powerful way
to allow users
to customize their
entire world on the web.
And ChromeVis
was an example of that.
Mazzoni: The last extension
I want to talk about
is called ChromeShades,
which we just released.
And this is different.
This is an accessibility tool
entirely for developers.
And in fact, it's entirely
for sighted developers.
Because I found myself
as a sighted developer
who is interested in building
more web applications
that are accessible
to people with screen readers
and magnifiers and other
assistive technology.
The problem I found
is that as a--
Because I'm not
a screen reader user,
it was a little bit
cumbersome for me
to keep turning on
a screen reader,
testing out my application,
then turning it off,
going back to coding,
because keeping it on
all the time and jabbering
is not the experience
I'm used to.
So I wanted a tool that would
help me find and identify
accessibility
problems quickly
without going through
the same experience.
And so ChromeShades
transforms your web page
into a visual experience
that helps highlight potential
accessibility problems.
It highlights which controls
are focusable and interactive
and different roles,
whether you're using ARIA
or whether you're
using native controls.
You can continue to interact
with your application
just as you would normally.
So you can test you
your whole application
and visually see at a glance
if there are any problems,
which can be a lot faster
for development.
So the source code
to all of these extensions
is available on Google code.
Of course everything here
is open-source.
And if you're interested in
how any of these things work
or if you have ideas
on how you can build
on any of these extensions
or the ideas behind them
to make things accessible
to different users
or just to get an idea
of how to make
your own web app accessible,
you can check out
the source code
or interact with us
by taking a look at that.
Shearer: And we're also
at the Developer Sandbox.
So if you want to talk
to us in person
and maybe try out
some of these extensions,
we'd be more than happy
to demo those for you.
But we've reached the end
of our presentation.
So I wanted to leave you
with a few final thoughts.
First of which is that,
as we said at the beginning
of the presentation,
an accessible website
does not have to be
a static, slow, HTML site.
With just a little bit
more work,
you can deliver
to your users
an interactive,
dynamic experience
that's gonna be
fun for them to use.
And the first step
down this road,
as I said as I was
stalling for time,
is just unplug your mouse.
All you have to do
is unplug your mouse
and try out your app
or your favorite web app
and you really might be
surprised at what you find.
It's the quickest way
to figure out
what the problems are
for users that aren't
gonna be using a mouse
to access your site.
And finally,
HTML5 and ARIA
are gonna get you
the rest of the way there.
With just a little bit
of extra work,
you can really give users
of assistive technology
an experience that rivals
the experience of any other user
without building
a separate page.
So it can be the same page
for everybody,
and that's really
the goal here.
So we hope you enjoyed
the presentation.
We hope that
you learned something.
We have a feedback
link at the top.
It's goo.gl/eWAqj
if you wrote that down.
We also have hashtags
if you can tweet
about the presentation.
And of course
the presentation code
is on our Google Code site.
And feel free to stop
by the Sandbox
and talk to us in person.
Mazzoni: Any questions
while we're right here?
Yeah, someone's coming up.
man: The--I looked on
the web store
for those extensions
you were just talking about.
I found ChromeShades
and ChromeVis,
but ChromeVox
was not listed.
Shearer: The reason--
Oh, sorry.
man: No, go ahead.
Shearer:
The reason why ChromeVox
is not on the web store
is because it uses
the experimental TTS API.
And because that's
still experimental,
we can't put it
on the gallery.
man: So how do you
install it then?
Shearer: On our
Google Code site,
you can actually get
the package CRX
and you can actually
also build it from source.
man: Thank you.
Mazzoni: So yeah, as soon as
the TTS extension
becomes a part
of stable Chrome,
we'll definitely put this
on the web store.
And we're planning also
a separate launch
with more features
to integrate with Chrome
on platforms other
than Chrome OS.
Today we're
essentially launching
for all users on Chrome OS
and essentially for developers
who are more comfortable
doing things
like building from source
or downloading and installing
the extensions separately.
So essentially this launch
of ChromeVox
on other platforms is for
the audience here, developers.
man: Hello.
Oh, okay.
So about managing the focus
on dialogs,
is there any other way
to keep the focus
from escaping that dialog,
instead of using JavaScript,
like using ARIA role
or a property
or something like that?
Mazzoni: So that's
a really good question.
The question is,
is there any other way
to keep focus inside of
something like a dialog?
I've experimented with this
a bit in different browsers
and screen readers.
There is no one solution
that works across all
browsers and screen readers
other than listening
for focus events,
because focus is not
a cancelable event
as part of the HTML standard.
So this is by design.
You can listen
to the focus event
and move it back.
There's one exception,
which is that if you're
using Safari on Mac OS X,
it implements the dialog
role slightly differently
so that it actually
treats the dialog
as essentially a separate
region of the page.
And by default,
all of the control
will be trapped
within the dialog
in Safari with
the Mac screen reader.
So users get a slightly
better experience there,
and they can choose to escape
the dialog with one extra step.
But across other browsers
right now there isn't
a solution for that.
That's something we're
definitely considering
for ChromeVox,
so it's a good question.
man: Okay, thanks.
Mazzoni:
Another question here.
man: Yeah, does ARIA validates
on W3C validator,
HTML5 validator,
or those kind of tools?
Mazzoni: The question was,
does ARIA validate
with W3C validators?
There might be
some ARIA tags that do,
but the experience we've had
is that validators work
great for static web pages.
And they're not going to help
in order to determine
whether something
really is accessible.
Validators should be
recognizing ARIA tags
as valid syntax
so they should tell you
that the syntax is correct,
but they're not
going to tell you
whether you've actually
semantically implemented
things correctly.
It's a little bit beyond
what a validator can do.
But this--since this is part
of the HTML5 standard,
there's no reason
it shouldn't validate.
man: Beyond what you'd
already talked about,
making an accessible website
that's also dynamic
and interesting,
do you foresee any issues
of being Section 508 compliant?
Mazzoni: Can you elaborate
on the question?
You're asking, like,
what other issues
do you see in being
Section 508 compliant?
Do you mean from the
perspective of a web developer
what else they need to do?
man: I was thinking more like
making an HTML5 website,
are there particular
complications
to being Section 508 compliant
that go beyond just,
you know,
what you've recommended
in this session?
Mazzoni: So what I would
say there is,
that Section 508 compliance--
for people who don't know,
it's a compliance standard
that essentially
gives a checklist of a bunch
of different ways
in which a website or lots
of other types of products
should be accessible
to people
with a wide range
of disabilities.
Section 508 compliant
is mostly,
at least for the web,
focused on things that are
a little bit more static
or just things like
whether something
can be interacted with
at all.
There are a lot of things
that we didn't cover
in this presentation
because there's a lot
of resources on it.
For example, a lot
of people are color-blind
or have partial low-vision,
so they might need
larger fonts.
We didn't talk
about those issues
because they don't relate
to interactivity.
We've been just talking about
the issue of interactivity.
And for interactivity,
the things we've talked about
in working with ARIA,
specifically the ARIA roles to
deal with interactive controls
and managing focus
and keyboard handlers,
those are the things
you need to do
in order to make
something work
when you've got
an interactive website.
But there are tons
of other aspects
to accessibility.
Most of those are not
necessarily affected
just because you have
an interactive Web 2.0 app
as opposed to, like,
a more static web page.
So there's tons of resources
on all the other types
of accessibility,
and if you want we can talk
about some of those offline.
And--Oh, another question
coming up.
man: HTML5 is also
about mobile applications.
Is there any supportive ARIA
in mobile browsers?
And how do you deal with
focus issues
on multi-touch devices
for instance?
Mazzoni: That's a really
good question.
There is some ARIA support
in mobile browsers already
on, like, right now
there's a great support
on the iPhone and iOS devices.
And you'll see
some cool things
coming to Android
at some point.
But yeah, focus
is definitely something
that can be different.
Right now I guess
I'll just say that
that on iOS there is
a concept of focus
when people are using
the voiceover on iOS.
And so a lot of these
things do apply.
But we could probably
do a whole talk
on accessibility
for mobile,
which is definitely
a different experience.
Shearer: It's definitely
something that's defin--
really an emerging field.
I mean, if you think back
even a few years ago,
it was only static,
you know, websites
that you could
see on mobile.
So this is
definitely something
where there's a lot of changes
happening very fast.
Mazzoni: That's a very good
question though.
man: Thanks.
Mazzoni: Okay, I don't see
any other questions,
but we'll be up here
if anyone wants to talk to us
about anything else.
And thank you very much.
Shearer: Thank you.